good morning so I'll have to say I'm
incredibly honored to be able to speak
to you today I always view MSR as the
place that disrupts and inspires
Microsoft and while I'm not a researcher
my team works incredibly closely with
MSR to funnel as many good ideas as we
can into the depths of the product teams
and so today I'll walk you through some
of the things that we're doing and how
we're thinking about approaching
responsible innovation around these
emerging technologies so first I thought
it might be good to just go back in time
and turn back the clock a little bit
what did the world look like ten years
ago do you remember do you remember what
it looked like in 2009 well in 2009 the
financial crisis was at its tail end
right
in March of o.9 the Dow Jones Industrial
Average had lost over 50% of its value
since October of 2007 this was the
economic context back then the iPhone
was just a year old do you remember that
I mean those wild right and every other
phone was pretty much outdated by the
end of 2009 so these phones just weren't
good enough by the end of that year the
App Store was five months old
remember that slogan there's an app for
that it was home to about 25,000 apps
the App Store now serves as one of the
most important software stores on the
planet there are over 20 million
registered developers two million apps
and in that decade the App Store has
generated over a hundred billion dollars
in revenue which is astounding the apps
were weird right they're kind of goofy
developers and users we're enjoying the
power of iPhones multi-touch display and
motion sensors this was the app that
everyone had to download it was the hook
to get you into the App Store really
sweet Amazon had just announced its
Kindle 2
which looks dramatically different now
Google had introduced an app that was
meant to transform the communication
space it was magical and new and it was
called Google Wave and we didn't quite
understand it at the time but it
combined email and messaging and social
media and event planning into something
that kind of looks like slack now and so
maybe Google was way ahead of its time
early in January of 2009 Facebook
surpassed MySpace
at the time Facebook was around 68
million monthly active users in the US
and this trend has continued Facebook
now has over 2 billion monthly active
users just incredible and then there was
this video that shocked all of us write
it rallied the world around a movement
Neda agha-soltan she was 26 years old
and she was shot dead it was captured by
a cell phone and uploaded to Facebook
and YouTube and it quickly went viral on
Twitter the media outlets like CNN
grabbed it and ran with it and Netta's
death set the stage for social media
activism and never before had citizens
in crisis been able to disseminate their
stories so easily to millions of
strangers around the world and this
really set the stage for the Arab Spring
that happened two years later and then
Kinect was first announced and this was
now under the codename of project natal
and it brought a multi-person skeletal
tracking face recognition voice
recognition to the mainstream making you
the controller and this left a lasting
impression in the technology world these
features soon began to percolate all
throughout the tech industry this is
kind of sweet minecraft was first
publicly available it led to a major
cultural transformation it's changed the
way that video games are perceived in
the classroom
teachers began using minecraft to teach
various lessons from circuitry to math
to history to language and and this has
been really interesting for teachers
because having a customizable 3d
environment gave them the opportunity to
teach lessons in a novel way in an
interactive way and minecraft still kind
of looks like this which is interesting
and so I would say that at that time we
were really early on
we'd probably a little blind to the
impact of technology may be a little
naive and really optimistic as well and
since then some would say that we're
living in an age of magic right the AI
revolution has occurred we have you know
seeing AI these assistive apps that help
people with low vision navigate the
world we're able to use vision
technologies and drones to go and check
on power lines we can track the
workforce and how they're operating in
their workflows in factory settings we
can use AI to track what's happening and
weather patterns in the environments
project Emma in the top right over here
is helping individuals with Parkinson's
disease and in reducing the tremors and
so this era is a really interesting one
and it's happened so quickly and if you
haven't been watching closely or you've
been heads down doing your work you
might be feeling like you're looking up
and finding a world that is quickly
shape and changing its shape around you
and in forming a new type of world
around you even for artists like myself
like this is my artwork I can take
original artwork like this and transform
it and create novel new artwork using
machines and this is an experiment where
we took 75,000 images of my art I create
video art we sampled it we trained a
neural net that would mimic mirror and
my style of artwork and I thought how
interesting I can collaborate with a
machine we can take words like a bird
with wings that are blue and
belly and generate completely novel
synthetic images this bird doesn't exist
in real not real life this is a
synthetic image and it was generated
based on this text and a neural network
that was trained on images of birds a
bird with wings that are black and a
white belly this bird also doesn't exist
in real life and a bird with wings that
are red and a yellow but yeah and that
yellow belly again another synthetic
image and this is really quite amazing
when you think about the power of using
language and converting it into imagery
and so we've seen massive shifts along
the perception and cognition services
the ability to reach human parody in in
certain categories and this has really
been quite incredible and if you think
about it we've spent the last thirty
years teaching people how to use
computers and we're now teaching
computers how to understand the world
and and this is one that's an amazing
field is transforming and changing lives
is transforming how we think about
technology and Microsoft has really been
leading the industry Microsoft research
has been leading the industry in
creating some of these amazing
breakthroughs as you look around along
mixed reality this is an innovation
that's transforming how people
collaborate and work it's allowing the
merging of the physical and digital
worlds to overlay virtual objects in
physical spaces lets you collaborate
over time over spaces and here is an
example of some field technicians
working with engineers and using the
hololens to collaborate with one another
there are assistive apps like seeing AI
that are built out of the suppose out of
my group and this is helping individuals
with low vision narrate the world around
them here's an example of the currency
reading experience in seeing AI and so
as we think about technology and how
it's transforming the world we're
starting to see it transform huge
industries from medical around skin
cancer diagnosis to a eyes that are
helping to detect when a heart attack
might occur to collaborating with
radiologists in the agriculture space
you know creating more efficiencies
real-time crop monitoring predictive
analytics to Big Pharma design drugs
being able to predict how chemicals and
compounds might interact and how they
work to target different molecules
autonomous vehicles the idea of taking
raw pixels and translating that to
steering commands really kind of
profound right and data centers thinking
about server workload and optimization
how do you reduce the downtime how do
you allocate staff and these are just
some categories right there's a huge
number of industries that are being
transformed so this is a massively
transformative set of technologies that
we're dealing with now very different
from 10 years ago and the debate the
flip side of this technology is equally
transformative we're no longer looking
at technology in that blind simplistic
utopian view the debate on the dystopian
side is equally real there's discussions
about addiction maximizers we see
individuals who are hooked on to
technology we're worried about that we
have questions are in automation and how
do individuals work in a space where
technology is quickly automating jobs
how do we think about autonomous weapons
we don't even have a definition of
autonomous weapons and we think about
bias blackbox algorithms deep fakes
fairness ethics corporate responsibility
the environmental impact human rights
privacy this notion of meaningful human
control right how do we think about
sustainability transparency surveillance
and then importantly the unintended
consequences and this is just a small
list of all of the topics it's obviously
a much larger list behind here but these
are some of the big topics that are
coming up in this category of work and
we can't really look away right now
right and so we've come to recognize the
incredible power of technology even the
pervasive of social media we're starting
to look at the power of face recognition
technologies and in a political climate
where both sides can't seem to agree on
anything they seem to be able to agree
that with face recognition this is a
technology that we need to regulate San
Francisco going even so far as to ban
this
technology synthetic media this year was
huge this is a huge leap in synthetic
media techniques being able to create
volumetric versions of people just using
images being able to clone voices using
small samples of speech and recorded
audio these technologies are massively
transformative I'm pretty sure Bill
Gates I'm going to go out on the limb
right now I'm pretty sure he didn't
consent to his voice being cloned and
these technologies can be used in deeply
harmful ways such as revenge porn and so
we're seeing a massive shift in the
capabilities of tech and also the
general societal reaction and perception
into how technology fits into our lives
okay and principles everyone has them
right every corporation every industry
group every Association everyone has
principles around how we should think
about emerging tech and it's important
it's important that this conversation is
happening this wasn't happening 10 years
ago I don't think anyone had principles
people weren't talking about this
leaders weren't talking about it that's
important and and so there's this
recognition that across the board we're
creating massively complex systems these
are impacting cultures they're
transforming the way we interact they're
transforming the landscapes and their
interactions between all of us and that
acknowledgement is an important one in
the industry and I think our language is
poorly suited to how we talk about the
complexity of technological interactions
these normal cause-and-effect metaphors
they don't quite work here and what
we're understanding is that we have to
look at technology in context because
most technology is often dual use and
it's difficult to separate the good and
the bad we need to understand how it's
being used by whom and what context
where and what the effects are and so
this is I think a really pivotal moment
for us in technology you're hearing our
leaders talking about this quite a bit
Satya has been incredibly bold in
shaping how Microsoft approaches
artificial intelligence and emerging
technologies some of you might recall at
Build a couple years ago he referenced
1984 had that up on the big screen and
talked about his concerns
about dystopia and dystopian futures
Masaccio talks a lot about building
trust you know building trust in
technology is crucial it starts with us
taking accountability for the algorithms
we make the experiences we create and
ensuring that there is more trust in
technology each day this was two years
ago every time he speaks he talks about
ethics and responsible innovation and so
this at Microsoft is an important
concept and at the corporate level we
have something called ether it's our
corporate ethics board it's an advisory
group I'm a member of it we look at big
topics that the company ought to
consider and come up with
recommendations for the for the company
but we've also recognized the need to
embed people who think about ethics and
responsible innovation deep in the
engineering stack and that's where I
said I sit in cloud and artificial
intelligence and we work alongside with
researchers engineers designers
developers and we look at how we can
augment those folks with responsible
thinking with techniques methodologies
in order for us to build this from the
bottom up and so I think you heard this
in the intro but my team is a guide and
we lead we help guide the the technical
experience innovation within cloud and
AI and and we have a mindset that is
really around stewardship and a
conservers society and the idea that we
have real deep concerns for the future
knowing that the decisions were making
right now have potential disruptive
destructive destructive impact in the
medium to long term and so this is the
mindset that we bring in to this group
and what I'd like to do is share with
you a little bit more about how we think
about responsible innovation deep in the
tech stack the idea here is that this is
about stewardship and it's about taking
care of the future through the decisions
we make around research innovation
development in the present and there's a
number of facets that we think about
when we say responsible innovation it
means reflexivity
inclusivity
anticipation responsiveness and
intentionality now I'm going to walk
through each one of these and share with
you how we think about it and kind of
break it down a little bit so a big
caveat first I think it's important to
say this we don't have all the answers
we can't stop that from us having
starting and and we are going to iterate
quickly and so we think about starting
somewhere learning as quickly as
possible and iterating iterating
methodologies iterating on mindset
innovating on tools and and we optimize
for creating a system where we can learn
as quickly as possible in the machine
learning space you often hear of
developers talking about their inner
loop and what they mean by that is the
inner loop between developing
experimenting testing and creating a
really tight group between iterating on
their models because the more you can
iterate and turn the crank on AI models
the better your models are and so we
think about this inner loop as the
ethics inner loop and how do we create
together with engineers designers PMS
and how do we create an inner loop that
helps us learn as quickly as possible
around these methodologies and I think
it's also important to recognize that
with any new tech there are huge domains
of ignorance that come up there are
things that we cannot possibly
understand or know or anticipate ahead
of time all of the new ecosystems and
unique circumstances surrounding
technology developments and so we know
that with every new technology
development these domains of ignorance
pop up and we need to create this space
for us to understand and excavate and
learn more and also create mechanisms
for listening to signal and and finding
you know Canaries in the coal mine so to
speak and so I want to kind of caveat
all of this with with these and and
lastly the fact that we're building on
amazing work from other people and other
disciplines in other industries I take a
lot of inspiration from Ursula Franklin
who was a Canadian physicist and her
thoughts around technology in the way
intersects with society we look at
Wendell Berry whose work
around sustainable agriculture was
really you know he was a thought leader
in his time and and we can apply a lot
of those techniques and ideas in the
technology space and then lastly in the
Science and Technology studies there are
people and disciplines whose work it is
to understand the impact of tech and
society as we want to leverage that
thinking and bring that to the forefront
so on the first category of reflexivity
the idea here is really about examining
our moral character and holding a mirror
up to what we're doing and why we're
doing it what are our motivations what
are we doing what our commitments what
assumptions are we making where are some
of our biases where do we think our
blind spots are what we're trying to do
here is have an honest conversation
about what we're doing and why and and
understand that we are trying to avoid
any sort of moral distancing that might
occur or the desire to look away from a
certain piece of technology and say you
know what I'm uncomfortable with it but
I'm just going to put my head over here
and pretend it doesn't exist we don't
want that to happen and so this is about
honesty and this is about openness it's
also about acknowledging that there's
very different views and value systems
around the world we're not a homogeneous
world we have diversity we have very
valid viewpoints that are not based in
Redmond Washington in the United States
and we have to acknowledge that we have
to bring that thinking into the way we
think we spend a lot of time looking at
organizational culture because we
recognize that organizational culture is
all about the values and behaviors that
happen and contribute to the environment
in which you build software and we want
to influence that we want to influence
how people interact the way they create
technology the way they share
information and and ultimately the most
some of our most important work is about
shaping the mindset of our workforce
because it's people that are building
technology and so I'll share with you a
few things that we're doing here and the
first one is an experiment that we're
running right now this is an experiment
where we're incorporating our principles
the things that Sasha is talking about
the things that Brad Smith is talking
about at the highest levels and we're
looking at incorp
that into our personal commitments and
reward system and so what does it look
like to tie principles of fairness into
your connect into your rewards what does
it look like to train the workforce to
understand and internalize and translate
that into how they change and do their
day-to-day work and so we've been
embarking on a number of workshops where
we actually work with groups to help
them write out their actual
accountabilities here's how they
translate to accountabilities we've
worked with training managers to
recognize the work that people are doing
and translate that into how they reward
individuals and so this this exercise of
translating principles into your day to
day actions is an important one because
sometimes they feel quite abstract and
sometimes they're hard to you know it's
hard to look at them say well what does
this mean for me what does it mean for
someone who's a build engineer working
on the system to have a system that is
fair what does it mean for someone who's
working and the design discipline and
maybe for those who are closest to the
tip of the spear it's actually easier
because they're thinking about
stakeholders and they're thinking about
who might be impacted but as you go down
the stack it becomes increasingly
difficult to take those abstract ideas
and then apply them and so we work on
breaking that down and helping people
think through those types of things and
then look at how we can change the whole
system so this is an experiment where
running is a few thousand people going
through it right now we're learning a
lot it's been a tremendous growth and
learning experience for all of us and as
we start scaling this type of practice
out again this is the way we we innovate
we do small experiments we iterate
really quickly and we learn and then we
start scaling it out based on what we
learn the second piece is around
inclusivity and the idea here is that
all the projects that we're working on
we want to vet them against competent
and diverse individuals we want to vet
them against people who bring
perspective and who might even object to
the work that we're doing because we
deeply believe in the value of diversity
and inclusion we want to hear from
people
who
don't believe in the work that we're
doing because we want to understand
what's happening there we want to create
the space for introspection we want to
create the space for challenging
dominant views we want to bring in
experts and leverage those capabilities
and we want to understand who's impacted
and start talking to those impacted
groups and and I'll say this you know
dominance systems they maintain
themselves and without diversity in the
room without people challenging that
system they don't change they reproduce
they maintain themselves and dominant
groups are rarely challenged to go and
even think about their dominance and so
this idea of listening to others of
incorporating feedback even when it's
uncomfortable that's a key element for
how we think about responsible
innovation and it's important that we
create the space for this in our
organizations things like open town
halls or we can have honest discussions
with leaders and ask pointed questions
things like having forums where you can
anonymously give feedback and have
people listen to it and take action on
it are important forums and we've
created those types of systems another
important one that we've created is
really around how we do research this is
around inquiry research validation and
almost all of the research that my team
does is on stakeholders who are
typically forgotten and these are
individuals who are often excluded from
mainstream research they're members of
social groups like the LGBTQ community
or minority groups women introverts and
these are individuals who are at risk of
harm in social situations and what we
want to do is we want to listen to these
groups that are typically excluded
children and the elderly are often
excluded right and so these types of
groups are important because we
understand that if we listen to these
marginalized groups we're better able to
address the needs of the broader range
of people and so we intentionally go and
recruit individuals to listen to their
feedback we want to hear how they think
about privacy I guarantee you that women
think about privacy different than men
do and if you design for women in
certain scenarios you actually address
the privacy needs for everyone and so we
take this mind
we start applying it to how we do
product development and this sort of
intentionality around just research and
who cuts gets to come into the room give
feedback to you on what you're building
and helps to shape it as an important
attribute for how you design responsible
technology so psychological safety is
something you hear everyone talking
about and this is I think one of the
critical pieces to creating a workforce
in an environment where people can speak
up and this is the you know the shared
belief that the team is safe for
interpersonal risk-taking you're able to
bring your real authentic self into work
without any sort of fear of negative
consequences that team members feel
accepted they're respected and in
creating this type of environment is an
ongoing task and it's easy to destroy it
and we're very thoughtful about how we
how do we create that and an example of
what we've done here is and this might
seem a little silly but it's actually
not it's we've created a card game that
we call judgment call and and this card
game has been interesting because what
it lets you do is it lets you exercise
your moral imagination and test your
analytical thinking in a really safe and
inclusive environment if anyone's
interested I've got a few of these and
you can come by and pick one up at the
end but but this card deck has been
unique because it really alters the
relationship and the environment for you
because when you enter into the context
of game play you suddenly open yourself
up to have conversations and dialogues
that you might not normally have you
give yourself the space to open up
issues and concerns and talk about it
because it's under the guise of gameplay
as part of the game right and so by
creating these types of tools and
mechanisms what you start to do is alter
the relationship between individuals and
give you the space and the freedom to
have the conversation so the game works
something like this there are three
different types of cards there's a
rating card one saying that the product
is extremely poor to five fantastic
exceptional there's a stakeholder card
where you have to enumerate all of the
different stakeholders that might be
using your product the direct ones the
end
one's and I'll tell you it's really hard
for people to think about stakeholders
and the you know vast spectrum of people
that might be using it just that
exercise alone of enumerated all the
different individuals that might
interact with your system not just the
ones paying for it but the ones who are
bystanders different advocacy groups
different types of individuals and so
they articulate different stakeholders
there's a set of cards that represent
the ethical principles that Microsoft
has publicly talked about now what you
start to do is you pair these cards up
and you get delta hand that says hey you
have a 1-star your stakeholder is an
elderly individual and your ethical
principle is all about fairness now you
write a review from the mindset of that
individual talking about the system or
product this is a replace you doing the
real research behind it to understand
how these people actually feel and and
how the product works for them but what
it does is it puts you in the mindset
and so this sort of activity pushes you
into that mindset where you're forced to
think about well what would I give a one
star like what would they say if it was
a one star review let's say it was a
face recognition system in an airport
what would you say you might say well I
keep getting pulled out of the lineup it
never really works for me I find I feel
targeted it feels really uncomfortable
and I really don't like the system it
seems to take longer to go through this
system than into the old one well that's
an interesting thing to capture right
and by writing down the review it gives
people the space to articulate some of
the concerns they might have about what
they're building because it is hard to
bring up negative things everyone is
interested in shipping everyone is
interested in moving the ball forward
stopping and pausing and having a
dialogue around what might be
problematic and what you're building we
want to create the space for that so we
put all of our new employees through
this boot camp we have them go through a
set of exercises we find lots of
different forums for us to share this
type of activity and this is really one
about building that muscle around
thinking about stakeholders creating
that safe environment to talk about
things that might not be ideal and
perfect and to be able to internalize
what do those ethical principles really
mean what does it mean to be fair what
does it mean to be transparent what does
it mean to be accountable here that sort
of thing okay so then the third category
is about anticipate
and looking around the corner thinking
ahead and what are some of the likely
outcomes not just what are all the
outcomes but what are the likely
outcomes what are the likely futures
what are some of the unintended
consequences and I think it's important
to recognize that there's no such thing
as just introducing technology
everything changes when you introduce
something you even the introduction of a
dishwasher changes the routines the
patterns and the relationships within a
family and so we have to think about how
we introduce technology in a really
thoughtful way intentional way and it's
important for us to be able to talk
about harm and break down this notion of
harm because we often say oh we don't
want to create technology that causes
harm nobody does alright nobody goes out
there and says hey I want to create tech
that's going to hurt harm someone but we
need to be able to break down what we
say when we say harm what does that mean
and for us what we did was we created a
set of operating foundations and
obviously there's a lot more than this
but three important ones that we wanted
to articulate as a company was first
upholding the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights second upholding the
principles the underpinnings of
democracy and third upholding the
mechanisms of an informed citizenry and
the third one's actually a component of
the second one but given some of the
technologies that we've seen enter the
space we actually wanted to pull this
one out and elevate it to a high level
and I'll show you in a second what I
mean by that so we broke down harm into
four major categories risk of injury
denial of consequential services and
those are things like education access
to public services the erosion of
democratic and societal structures and
that's why I've shown you that third
foundational pillar because we are
seeing a lot of technologies that are
having an impact on societal structures
and we wanted to call that category out
as a top level because that's something
that we're seeing and then the
infringement on human rights and we
broke this down into categories and it's
been broken down into sub further sub
categories with questions underneath
each one but the idea here is we want to
create a framework for how we think
about harm because harm is a complicated
topic and it is difficult for people to
say what do we mean and we
wanted to break it down and this is
probably going to get tweaked if you
come back to me in three months this
will look different because we're going
to learn and we're gonna find things
we've missed we're going to find nuances
that we wanted to capture that we
haven't captured here but the idea is
here like in risk of injury we're
thinking about the emotional and
psychological distress that technology
can cause people think about the effect
of deep fakes on people right the
physical infrastructure damage that
think that technology could affect
opportunity loss economic loss the loss
of agency manipulation social detriment
loss of Liberty loss of privacy loss of
dignity and like I said underneath this
as an entire set of categories that
breaks down what we mean by each of
these larger categories but then what
we've done is we've taken some of our
tech and we've started applying a lens
on top of this and saying hey what does
this tech actually do or does it think
if you were to put your tinfoil hat on
and think about the worst things and the
worst likely things that could happen in
the worst hands and the different ways
you could exploit or abuse and
manipulate this tech what could happen
and here's an example of one project
where we said look this has potential
for psychological distress or right
about that manipulation it can affect
how people make money we think this
might affect the freedoms that people
might have like this is an example rate
of how you might now layer on a lens and
some level of analytical thinking and by
no means is this perfect there is no
like rubric in the back that gives you
like a score at the end of this this is
a judgment call and it all depends on
who's in the room and making sure the
right people are in the room having the
dialogue around this because some of
this is a judgment and leveraging
research and the latest knowledge in
developing this kind of framework
there's multiple characteristics right
how severe is the impact what's the
scale is there disproportionate impact
with the likelihood of exposure if
you've done any sort of threat modeling
this will seem very familiar right ease
of updating the system this is an
interesting one some systems are much
harder to update when you've discovered
that they cause some low blow heart so
hardware for example if you need to make
an update that has a longer life cycle
and lead time to making updates we need
to be extra careful around hardware
and so we start thinking about these
various facets and characteristics of
systems and then we can start applying
this lens and so there's some rigor that
we want to apply here and then there's
also the understanding around
infrastructure because infrastructure
emerges all around us and that
infrastructure lends to certain types of
technologies growing perpetuating and
once technology is widely accepted and
standardized there's a relationship that
changes between people who use the
system you suddenly have less and less
power as a user once a system has been
broadly standardized and widely accepted
and that's not the type of relationship
that we want to design and so we want to
be really intentional to understand here
what kind of infrastructure is starting
to pop up around some of these
technologies because that will give us a
little bit of a clue into the direction
that some of this technology is heading
okay so the fourth one is around
responsiveness and the idea here is new
knowledge is emerging all the time
norms are changing technology is
changing people's perspectives and their
views on technology are changing and we
have to respond to it we can't carve
things in stone and say this is how we
think about harm that will not change
what we need to change as things change
right and this changes
disproportionately around the world and
we have to be aware of the worldwide
impact and view and so the landscape is
shifting dramatically and we're actively
adjusting and responding likewise and so
a few years ago we did some research
this is now old but I thought I would
share this here because we started
looking at the socio-political
environment and how does that affect the
belief systems and how people feel about
technology where they have fear where
they have security we started looking at
the intersection of how people think
about the kinds of relationships they
want to have with technology the kinds
of experience they have had with
technology and then we look at context
and so how do some of these technologies
pervade throughout people's lives were
the situations that people find
themselves in day to day and we know
that norms are built in
you know more than that just these three
circles but these are some important
ones for us to consider and we did some
research a few years ago we looked at
different countries and different
variations on trust because we wanted to
understand well what was the difference
and how people looked at technology how
they thought about technology in the
government and in the u.s. we found that
a lot of people had a lot of skepticism
both around corporations and the
government people felt like no one was
looking out for them that the government
was there too there was a lot of
suspicion around the government
supporting businesses over citizens
interests I bet some of this is still
accurate
I'd be more so in China and for the
people and I'll caveat this you know for
the people that chose to speak with us
there was higher trust in corporation
than government because they tended to
work a little bit more in tandem and
people were starting to see the benefits
of government and corporations working
together for the collective citizens
Germany is quite different right there's
some tougher regulation in the in Europe
and so there was more trust in the US in
the government's ability to regulate
regulate corporations I think this has
changed a little bit too since we've
done this
ethnography but the idea here is that
around the world there are different
relationships that people have with
technology with government with
corporations and we need to factor that
into how we think about rolling out new
technologies because it is not just the
US and so lastly I want to talk a little
bit about intentionality and how do we
design with principles how do we design
with intention with appropriate
technologies and so this is where Sachi
I think in 2016 share these principles
around ethical AI development the
principle of fairness that all
stakeholders should be treated equitably
and that we want to prevent undesirable
stereotypes and biases this notion of
systems being robust and reliable that
they perform well in the worst case
scenarios across different environmental
factors
privacy and security is a big
underpinning of at Microsoft that all of
our data we want to prevent it from
misuse and unintended access we think
about privacy in a pretty robust way at
the company inclusion is really about
empowering everyone regardless of their
abilities making sure that people have
ways to give feedback and transparency
is all around these black box algorithms
and how do we ensure that whatever these
algorithms are doing they they're
understood by the stakeholders and
people that are interrogating the system
and then lastly principles around
accountability and ensuring that we as a
company as individuals take
responsibility for what we build and
what the impact is and that's why we're
being so thoughtful and intentional
especially at the engineering level
around how we develop tech and one of
our researchers Salima Amir she has done
an incredible amount of work where she's
gone and scoured 150 plus AI
recommendations conducted multiple
rounds of iteration and validation and
looking at what are some of the
guidelines we should have around human
AI collaboration and and each of these
has examples and proof points that we
can point people to and say hey if you
want to do X here's some examples here's
some good examples of what you can do
this is publicly available her research
papers out there and and things that we
do here are you know how do we be super
transparent about technology so we
recently published something called a
transparency note for face recognition
we recognize that there's a lot of
complexity and face recognition and we
want to make sure that people understand
how the technology works what the
capabilities are what the limitations
are how to achieve the best results as a
company as technology companies they
rarely open the lid and say here's where
it just doesn't work you guys don't do
it like this don't use it here what we
wanted to do is create a mechanism for
us to be able to share what is the most
appropriate use of technology and we
want you to understand the complexity
here I want to understand what can cause
false positives false negatives what can
you do as a customer to create the most
appropriate use and deployment of a
piece of technology and so this sits
somewhere between marketing material
which is often meant to make products
look amazing and develop your API is
which is really functional it's
somewhere in between and it's about
capabilities how something works and how
to help guide the deployment of this for
responsible use and this is a pattern
that we're starting to use across other
technologies and then there's this
concept of being seen full right in
technology and in software we're often
striving to create a seamless as an
experience as possible and there's many
benefits to this sort of seamless
philosophy it's easier right if it looks
beautiful it's frictionless but
sometimes we want to insert speed bumps
they want to insert friction because we
want to encourage conscious decision
making and so this is where we put
controls in place around privacy
identity exchanges of information and we
intentionally want to show you where the
seams are because we want you to stop
and pause as an individual as a customer
and make a conscious decision and I
think AJ talked about this in the
lightning round this morning we've been
doing a lot of work to put ethics in the
code path and really what we want to do
is we want to translate what someone
says at a policy level and translate
that into lines of code what does it
mean and this is an example of an
automated tool that we're building that
extracts out conditions where errors are
happening in a model as part of a
developer's workflow and this is a
prototype it's something that we're
actively developing but it's designed to
sit within the developers code flow and
what it does is as you look through the
chart here
it breaks down a models behavior and
here's an example if someone's going
through it saying okay four females who
are not wearing eye makeup who have
short hair and are not smiling we have a
whole bunch of errors so we not we don't
look at just females and there's a big
bucket of errors around female let's go
recruit more females what we can start
doing is breaking down the model
performance and saying for this category
of people we have problems we have gaps
this model is not performing well well
let's go understand that let's go look
at whether we have enough data whether
we need to acquire more how's that model
performing this sort of tooling and
inquiry is what we mean by explainable
AI we want to be able to understand how
a model is performing and and so there's
a lot of things like this that we're
introducing
right into the infrastructure and the
engine of how we're developing code and
it's meant to just it's part of your
process it's just how you do work in the
new world and so as we examine our
ecosystem as we examine the technologies
our building and we say okay what are
the attributes of good systems what do
they look like and here I think this is
more an inspiration from Wendell Berry
and sustainable agriculture because a
lot of the patterns that he was
describing years ago are very similar to
good patterns in technology good
ecosystems function in harmony with the
larger patterns right they're pragmatic
there's no science fiction and crazy
stuff going on it's nothing far-fetched
it solves real problems and there are
reasonable limits to it it's something
more than one problem it's not doing
things in piecemeal fashion it's solving
complex problems in a holistic way well
what do bad solutions look like these
seem very similar to the way a disease
might behave or an addiction might
behave within a body we see addictive
behaviors right now we see we're seeing
it right now with social media right
these types of bad solutions cause new
sets of problems that are equally as bad
as the one that's trying to solve it
might worsen a problem I might feel
heavy-handed it fails it's really
brittle and so as we examine good and
bad systems we want to be able to
identify what do they look like what are
some of the attributes around them so
let me step back a little bit and just
talk a little bit again about the big
picture because technology need not be
used the way we use them today and it's
not a question of no technology or the
you know putting up with the current
ones we should actively be pushing up
against technological determinism and we
should be asking questions about that
looking at the big picture at the same
time as we're looking at some of the
details and so fundamentally what I
think we need to do and what we're doing
is we should be approaching this type of
thinking as innovation material it's not
a tax it's not a compliance it's not an
after-the-fact it's not something you
tack on and say okay now let's make this
responsible that's put some band-aids on
it it's starting to think about it right
from the beginning the way we think
about privacy and security right from
the
set of development and innovation
material it's an opportunity right it's
a business opportunity and and so this
is a mindset that my team brings into
this world
like I said we're embedded at the
deepest part of the infrastructure we're
embedded in the place we look at all of
the face recognition text speech people
technologies ambient technologies mixed
realities all of these types of
synthetic environments as well this is
where we see some of these technologies
start to incubate and we want to do
those in the most responsible way
possible so I think I have 10 or 15
minutes left
and I'll leave it at that and see if
anyone has questions thank you okay so
we have some micro neurs and I see a
number two here yeah hi there so thanks
for your talk I think it's it's
wonderful to see a company embedding
ethics deeply in its process and I'm
enthusiastic about your efforts to try
and do good I'm more pessimistic about
your efforts to not be evil because
you're only one company and if you're
not evil than some other startup company
will be evil instead and we'll get the
same technology and I think the only way
to prevent those sorts of of outcomes is
to legislate and actually have rules
that apply to all companies and so I'm
curious whether your ethical team at
Microsoft is working with your lobbying
team to try and influence legislation
going forward yeah absolutely and I
agree with your sentiment that the thing
that applies to everyone our laws well
there's and there's two pieces here one
is what can we as a company do as a
trillion dollar company in the world
what can we do to raise the floor and
the water level for the industry and and
I think we have the benefit of being
around the block a few times right we
went through our own era of growing up
and our
own adolescent years and so we are a
much more mature company than some of
the newer ones that are going through
very publicly some learning and so we
can set a lot of examples by us talking
about this publicly we're setting
examples by us talking to the industry
by participating in things like the
partnership on AI we talk about things
and techniques publicly so that we can
give people ideas and give them tools so
that they may go and implement them as
well because a lot of companies do want
to do good and and what they're looking
for our examples they're not quite sure
how to approach it they might be a
little new they're not sure how to
organizationally situate themselves and
so we want to give them examples on the
regulation side you've probably seen
this Brad Smith has publicly called for
regulation around face recognition my
group works very closely with our legal
team as well with our lobbyists as well
and what we and what we think our role
is we want to give proof points we want
to show people what it means when we say
here's a policy well it's kind of
abstract sometimes and the best policy
is one where you can point to a proof
point and say here's how its articulated
so we do work closely with them our
focus is not around lobbying and
regulation but there are parts of the
company that are focused on that we'd
collaborate with them so an old cliche
says talk is cheap action count Apple
has done publicly and says what happens
on your iPhone stays on your iPhone and
this tech the position with respect to
privacy well what's my Microsoft
position on and we heard yesterday I
talked a behavioral data in the wealth
of behavioral data the question of
course who gets to see this behavioral
data
so what's Microsoft position on
behavioral data and would Microsoft step
up to the same place what stays on your
laptop or you know vice there's a new
device that's interesting so I don't
know the talk that you're referring to
around behavioral data that happened
yesterday but I'll say that both Apple
and Microsoft are are some of the
conscious leaders in the industry and so
when you look at the cases Microsoft has
brought to court the where they have
challenged the government the way that
they choose where data centers
exist and the evaluations that are done
around countries and human rights I
would say that there's a lot of very
public discussion that does translate
into actions that are meaningful
multi-million billion-dollar decisions
that are being made Brad has talked
about decisions that we've made as a
company where we chose not to sells
technology to certain regimes or took it
where we've chosen not to sell
technology to for example a California
Police Department that wanted to go and
deploy face recognition and you know
body cams dash cams and we've said you
know what no we don't think that this
technology is fit for purpose we don't
we have concerns about how you would use
this we've said no to countries that
have wanted to deploy technology across
their capital cities and and we've
looked at their human rights records and
potential violations that might occur
and we said no we don't want to put
technology there and so we let's go back
to behavioral data yeah I am electing
I'm not an expert on the behavioral data
side so you know we can talk about that
afterwards and I could find you a
contact because I think the behavioral
data there's lots of places where would
appear in office potentially LinkedIn
potentially but those are just not
categories that I spend a lot of time in
but I can find you a contact or someone
to talk to around behavioral data hi so
at a moment we see sort of globalization
and open source two of those things that
limit the impact so if you decide face
recognition on body cams is not
something Microsoft would want to sell
but at the same time Microsoft would put
out things as open-source or libraries
at open source the level of knowledge
required to put it into action for
somebody else goes down and I think so
for me this question I coming from
Germany I think regulation as one of
those things we have seen and it's
really hard if you want to maintain an
open market and they see if you want to
have your citizen access everything
around the world so how do you see
service in one way it's very clear we
can do it from always sort of a
our own perspective our own country's
perspective but we have the global view
and then sort of probably what we agree
globally becomes very very small like
the human rights even there we see sort
of looking around the world so how do
you see the sort of the open sourcing
which basically lowers the hurdle for
artists to change things as well as the
globalization in order to have success
with sort of the ethical principles we
put out as sort of some like companies
some states but if the others don't join
in is it going to work yeah I know
that's a tough question and and we
talked about this quite a bit which is
if we choose to do something but others
if we choose to not go into a certain
business and others do what does that do
and this is where again the question
about regulation comes in and and at the
end of the day there is a there's a
distinction here because we're talking
about how we govern our behavior we're
not talking about us governing the world
this is about us governing our behavior
as a company where we choose to put our
time and energy and investment and so we
have to distinguish that because it's
easy to say well how does Microsoft go
and shape the world this is primarily
about how do we shape ourselves first
and at the same time can we shape the
world in a positive way but but it's not
our job to go and police the world and
so we have to think about that as first
just a way a mindset around this is
about us managing ourselves the the open
source question is a really interesting
one we've had a lot of debate around
this discussion I would say and I think
you recently saw a dataset that was
pulled off and Microsoft pulled it
offline we said look we just don't feel
good about this data set right now the
researcher that was working on this no
longer at the company let's pull this
one off line because we have concerns
about what might be in it and we want to
be really thoughtful about it and so
we're actively going in and examining
some of these and some and that's an
example of that one in addition so I
think it goes all the way to the tools
because tools make it so much easy to do
the things and I think you're conscious
about sort of that the product to sell
but I think would it really sort of make
it
yeah what is required that we don't sell
tools to people yeah and and so the the
angle that we are actually coming at it
is from a platform so I sit in the
platform at Microsoft I don't sit in the
here's the actual piece of software or a
product that's shipped we sit in the
platform we power Cortana we power all
of the speech language vision services
around the company and then we provide
that platform to developers and so the
discussion is around what do we provide
some of these platforms and and what
technologies are actually gated which
ones are gated which ones need extra
scrutiny and face recognition is one of
those technologies and and so we think
about this at the platform level as well
I think that's the deepest level we need
to think about it and this is where it
gets super messy because you don't
always know how your platform is being
used as soon as you open it up and it
enters the market you lose all control
over it and so the dialogue around which
ones are the most are problematic and
and can we articulate then identify and
then do we have systems in place to
manage who uses it and how it's used
that's a needle we're trying to thread
right now yeah hi I'm Margaret Burnett
from Oregon State I really enjoyed your
talk and my question is sort of about a
trajectory as you see it now on on
Microsoft's organizational culture so it
seems like this this trend that you're
describing now actually started several
years ago and so you know over time it
it seems like it's grown you're
reflexivity and you're thinking about
your products in this way and my
question is what kinds of changes have
you seen that you can actually measure
in Microsoft's organizational culture
well organizational culture is hard to
measure it I mean it's hard to measure
but well let me I'll share some
anecdotes how about that because well
one thing we do is we measure literacy
around principles and values just to
understand whether people understand
what they need and whether they can
apply so that we
measured through surveys and things like
that but but I want to talk a little bit
about behaviors and and what we're
seeing are people starting to ask a lot
more questions and starting to say hey
you know what I actually want to change
how we do budgeting around data
acquisition because what we want to do
this year for example is we want to go
create a fair benchmark data set and
creating a fair benchmark data set costs
a lot more money than just creating any
old data set where you just go and
gather as much data as you can and so
we're starting to see changes in
behavior that affect the way you budget
the way you plan for technologies we
have people that come to us and say I'm
starting to articulate things that I've
never felt comfortable talking about we
have people that have come to us and say
I need to rethink in my career what I'm
doing Mira I need to go quit my job and
I say don't quit your job change how
you're doing your job and so there are
these cultural transformations that are
really behavioral that you start to see
we as an ethics group I mean nobody
wants to ethics group at the beginning
right you've got an engineer that you're
gonna slow me down and that's the
initial reaction we get pulled into a
lot of conversations where they say hey
we want to think about this right at the
beginning or another group will say I
heard about what you guys did with that
group can you come and help us and so
the types of asks we get and the
questions and the way we get pulled in
we've seen even in the last year in the
last two years a huge shift just in the
way people approach us because initially
there's a fear of oh you guys are the
ones waving a stick you're gonna tell me
I can't do what I would do and then we
hear wait you're actually my partner you
made me do something better and faster
and I didn't have time for that thank
you so much and so it's those types of
things that we listen to and that's how
we understand whether this is actually
having the kind of cultural shift we
want this year what we did was at least
in this organization we change how we do
budgeting we force groups to factor in
their ethical needs I guess I don't know
if there's a better way of putting this
but we forced them to think through all
of the things that come with the
responsible innovation all the new data
acquisition that they have to do any new
benchmarks any new tooling that they
have to build and they factor that into
their budgeting process and I found that
really remarkable because I haven't seen
that and heard about that elsewhere and
so that to me is another signal that
things are shifting and changing thank
you hi there um there was one up there I
think I saw you waving number three oh
hi thank you for the talk this is really
interesting I particularly like this
idea of ethicists embedded and product
groups some science and one thing that
I'm just wondering about it seems like a
lot of Industry anybody can be an
ethicist right in the sense that you
have to have a computer science degree
and go through a loop in our interview
and become a software developer but you
don't really need any qualifications to
be an ethicist
and I wonder if Microsoft is thinking
about this somewhat differently do you
have to have a degree in philosophy or
degree in ethics or do you have to have
passed some bar before you are leading
the ethics decisions of a team how does
it work yeah so the group is actually
multidisciplinary and so there are only
a handful of people that I would say are
like the true ethicists on the team the
the organization that I run has data
scientists creative coders designers PMS
and you know one or two people that I
would say are more ethics oriented
because this isn't really just about
ethics this is about how you develop and
so we create proof points we create
through code and design and show you
here's another way to do it and so the
ethics you know the the thinking around
the on the ethics side and which type of
ethical philosophy you align to isn't
really the high order bit the word
ethics is used often and you would think
that there might be it's all Ephesus
it's not and so I think the trick here
is is to not 1 don't hire people who are
just armchair ethicists and who have
some level of experience in background
and so we make sure that they've got
some degree in philosophy and they've
worked in the industry for a while
but but these types of groups are not
effective if they're only talk they have
to do and they have to show and so we
staffs the group in such a way that data
scientists can go in and examine the
data in the composition a coder could go
in and that example of the error
analysis tool that I showed that was
created I was coded by someone on our
team that did you know the front end of
it so we could understand what how it
will manifest and that wasn't an
emphasis it was someone coding it in a
responsible way so I think the shift has
to really happen away from ethics as the
talking point to responsible innovation
which change it's an engineering
function as well thank you there's two
in the back thank you I'm so I was
really interested that I could remember
UC Davis I was really interested in your
training program and I was wondering
whether you had any curricular materials
that you could share and more broadly
and what advice do you have for
developing curriculum materials in
undergraduate social engineering
programs so no no curriculum that we're
ready to share yet but we hope to make
things public but I'll say that
curriculum needs to be tailored to your
cultural environment in the context in
which you're developing if it's too
abstract
it's just theory at that point and
theory doesn't really land well with
engineers you want to you want to show
real practical here's what you should do
and here's how you should think about it
and so we've tailored our stuff to our
environment
the dialogue we have is around the
technologies that we're building and so
it's not too far removed because then
you have people saying I just don't get
what you're trying to say and so I think
it has to be really tailored and so when
we share it it'll look tailored to what
we're doing in our group I'm happy to
talk about just education curriculum
afterwards if you want because I think
that that's a longer conversation and it
depends on what the outcomes are that
you're trying to achieve and and things
like that so I think that that's a
longer deeper conversation I'm happy to
chat after this if you want to come up
okay any more questions one more up here
a lot of people seem to be talking about
intentionality these days but there's
not that much agreement on definitions
and I was wondering what youth how you
see intention and what you think it's
sort of important disease yeah it's a
it's a good question I haven't heard a
lot of people talking about
intentionality I just hear a lot of
people talking about principles right
now and but the way that we talk about
intentionality is that every decision
you're making there's a reason behind it
you've thought about it you've been able
to think about who's impacted how and
what and like have you asked why five
times and gotten to the essence of what
you're doing where you're you know we're
doing some work around just user flows
right now around some of our devices and
being really thoughtful about how are
people going through that flow how are
they
consenting and giving information and so
that instead of like it's so quickly to
go and draw Golden Path scenarios and
and don't not think of the stress cases
the cases where people will trip up the
cases where it will not work for
everyone and so we're trying to do is
bring that stakeholders value sensitive
design into the system and start
thinking through well how do it how do
people use it how does it degrade how
does it fall apart and so when I think
of intentionality it depends on the
stack and the discipline so designers
will think about it from it may be a
stakeholder standpoint intentionality at
the deepest level of code is different
it's more about robustness understanding
the environmental factors and so I think
you have to break it down by discipline
and category of work but but it is being
able to answer why and why did you make
that decision and what's the information
you're using the power
it can't be your gut and where you have
no data you have to make good choices
but where you can reasonably go and
collect data there is not there's no
excuse to not go and do that and so can
we rely on research and can we rely on
listening to people and understanding
it's being used in context and so it's
it's being really informed and more
data-driven about it when you when you
have the ability to do that it looks
like there's one more question over here
Tara okay thank you so much for another
raw discussion and I'm just wondering
you mentioned about intention of
building this trust and one way to build
trust is when you actually have the
openness of the flawed has happened and
I wonder if Microsoft or you could
perhaps facilitate a roundtable with the
tech giants in us really to actually
have this kind of discussion but really
in a roundtable what do I have that been
done that could you know it could be
rectified that you know you know moving
forward together on this ethical
framework and I think when you know one
thing that you mentioned building on the
works of others if if Microsoft could
embrace the rest of the tech giants to
move together within this I think a
responsible framework I'm sure the rest
will follow
yeah you know that's a that's a really
good point and so there's actually a few
things that are happening in the space
and I'll touch on two one is the
partnership on AI has a number of work
streams that we're involved in other
companies are involved in there's a sort
of work streams around synthetic media
deep fakes how do we collaborate with
newsrooms to help them learn how to
identify some of this tech some of these
synthetic pieces of media that are
coming into the system and so there's a
lot of collaboration happening the
partnership on AI has been really
amazing it took a while for it to get
spun up but it's been really amazing in
facilitating open conversations there's
also a lot of maybe more ad hoc private
conversations that happen between the
industry that I haven't seen happen
before that I'm involved in as well
where we do get together and we say
because it's working and here's what is
in what are you what's working for you
guys hey sure some of those techniques
over here and so there's a sharing of
information that's happening we share
our methodologies ideas and I think
there has to be a larger investment in
this category I mean we are investing
huge compared to I
to other companies I remember my son the
other day he was I came on what do you
work on ethics responsible attack and
he's like how many people work on that
we back of the napkin some rough you
know
ten-year-old math and he said well how
BIG's the industry shouldn't more people
work on that and this is my ten-year-old
asking this question and I think more
people should work on it and so there is
there's existing conversations we're
trying to facilitate other ones are
trying to facilitate ones with industry
and in different categories of people
that use the technology it's starting
sometimes they're not as like vocal
about it as maybe they ought to be and
and I think your feedback around hey can
you guys be more like open about sharing
that is a good one okay so I think we're
a ten minutes after you guys have lots
of demo booths to go take a look at I'm
happy to answer questions if you
afterwards just informally if you want
so thank you very much
[Applause]